To draw a straight line, we only need 2 points. We have point a and we have some
other point, then the shortest path between them, is just a straight line. If we
had just 1 point on its own, we wouldn't know what direction to draw the line
in, unless we had another point that we knew we needed to aim toward. If we want
to check that this actually the line that we were looking for, however, we need
1 more point that supposedly lies on the line, to check that this is the correct
line. So, we need 3 points, if we want to check our original line. So, maybe
this point right here, is the third point that I had in addition to these two.
We can see if the original line I was starting to draw goes through this point
as well. And voila, we have one continuous beautiful line. Let's say, for
example, that I had 3 points, and I thought that they all lay on the same line,
because I thought that I had done my xy table correctly. Unfortunately, when I
bring my ruler into the picture, there is no way that I can get a line that I
would draw along my ruler to contain all 3 of these points. So clearly, one of
my coordinates must be messed up. So, a lot of the time, just to be safe, it's
great to have 3 points that you think satisfy your equation, just to make sure
your graph is correct.